[Music]
we're kicking off summer with a new card
like what better way than to work hard
and also play play fun PC is here at the
simplifier summer event with American
Express as they launch their new cash
magnet card
tell us what guests are in for today
just fun stuff they're gonna get to play
and try new cocktails and share with
each other and connect and do it in a
way that makes us feel encouraged for
being businesspeople and for working so
hard and having our dreams and pursuing
it just being a father and being busy
what season two of where I coming out I
need to make sure that my summers are
simple and easy and that's why I
partnered with the American expression
cash magnet so what are your top tips
for simplifying your summer I find time
to connect with my family and also make
sure you spend at least four out of the
seven nights hanging with friends a lot
of play with my little ones I think
that's super important that keeps you
really young because it keeps you
exercising a great deal when you work so
hard and you have all these expenses you
want to make sure that you're using a
card without adds value to you back and
I feel that the cash back card does just
that it rewards you in a sense that you
get 1.5% out of all the cash that you
spend on it so that's like an instant
gratification for more details on how
you can make your busy lifestyle a lot
simpler head over to American Express
comm flash cash magnet card
[Music]